Katrina:  然后我们有那种大音箱不
Katrina: And then do we have those big speakers?
Shure:  这个可以有
Shure: We can have that
Katrina:  如果在外面玩的话放点音乐啥
Katrina: If we play outside, we can put on some music
Jake: 嗯就放刚刚那个曲子
Katrina: Yeah, just play that song we had
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Hmm, right.
Alice: 嗯大东北
Katrina: Hmm, Northeast.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Katrina:  知识问答自我介绍
Katrina: Knowledge quiz self-introduction.
Jake: 打死我吧
Jake: Just kill me.
Jake: 这个花瓶
Jake: This vase.
Katrina:  这是真的酒还是假酒
Katrina: Is this real wine or fake wine?
Jake: 假酒
Jake: Fake wine.
Katrina: 啊我还以为你们已经喝了
Katrina: Ah, I thought you guys already drank it.
Jake: 这是我的水瓶
Jake: This is my water bottle.
Jake: 没有啥毛病哦
Jake: There's nothing wrong with it.
Katrina:  再拿起出来干一口
Katrina: Take another sip from it.
Jake: 那花瓶拿走了还倒
Jake: The vase is gone, still pouring.
Katrina:  这多的话等会就放
Katrina: There’s more, just wait a bit.
Katrina:  这花瓶好
Katrina: This vase is good.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Shure: 完了
Shure: Done.
Alice: 叮零咣当的
Alice: Clang clang.
Shure:  这是个保温杯啊
Shure: This is a thermos.
Lucia: 这居然是保温杯
Lucia: This is actually a thermos.
Shure:  一听就是304不锈钢
Shure: You can tell it's 304 stainless steel.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 厉害了
Lucia: Impressive.
Jake: 很懂啊大东北
Jake: You know a lot, Northeast.
Jake: 衬衫的是吧
Jake: Shirt, right?
Jake: 东北钢铁厂
Jake: Northeastern steel mill.
Shure:  安钢
Shure: Angang.
Shure:  这字写的太好看了
Shure: The writing is so beautiful.
Shure:  真的
Shure: Really.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  可歌可泣
Shure: So moving.
Jake: 一看就是中文
Jake: Obviously in Chinese.
Shure:  哦我们还要写个英文版吗
Shure: Oh, do we need to write an English version too?
Shure:  不用不用不用
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake: 哎呦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake: 我们字写的好
Jake: Our writing is good.
Jake: 我们应该international一点
Jake: We should be a bit more international.
Shure:  你看我那个英文就明显跟这个
Shure: Look at my English, it's clearly...
Jake: 那好下面开始写英文吧
Jake: Alright, let's start writing in English then.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:时间线
Jake: Timeline.
Jake: 来
Jake: Here.
Shure: 来咱俩换一下
Shure: Let's switch.
Shure:  你去那边坐一会去
Shure: You go sit over there for a bit.
Jake: 或坐这
Jake: Or sit here.
Shure:  timeline
Shure: Timeline.
Jake:为啥是俩词
Jake: Why is it two words?
Alice: 时间线吧
Alice: It's timeline.
Jake: 为啥是俩词
Jake: Why is it two words?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This...
Jake:也行也行
Jake: Works, works.
Shure:  强调一下这个life
Shure: Emphasize this "life".
Shure: 线
Shure: Timeline.
Jake:好好
Jake: Good.
Shure:  首先我们几点入场
Shure: First, what time do we start entering?
Jake: 3点 3点吧
Jake: 3 PM, right?
Jake: 应该是2点到3点逐步入场
Jake: Should be staggered entry from 2 PM to 3 PM.
Jake: 然后前面可能签到的人
Jake: Then those who signed in earlier...
Katrina: 逛逛
Katrina: Walk around.
Jake: 都会给他们一点活动
Jake: We'll give them some activities.
Shure:  鹌鹑
Shure: Quail.
Jake:哈哈神经
Jake: Haha, you're crazy
Jake: 入场是怎么拍的吗
Jake: How's the entrance shot?
Lucia: 2点半到3点
Lucia: From 2:30 to 3:00
Shure:  okay对
Shure: Okay, right
Jake: 这意思就是3点之前
Jake: So that means before 3:00
Jake: 我们搞一些flexible的游戏或者活动
Jake: We do some flexible games or activities
Jake: 然后3点准时干点什么东西
Jake: And then at 3:00 we do something specific
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah
Shure:  game
Shure: Game
Shure:  before
Shure: Before
Shure:  是不是污染数据
Shure: Is it polluting the data?
Shure:  极不污染
Shure: Definitely not polluting
Jake: 这是人类的正常行为
Jake: It's normal human behavior
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah
Shure: ：ok第二点还有什么
Shure: Okay, what's the second point?
Shure:  还有什么然后
Shure: What's next then?
Jake: 然后3点干啥了
Jake: Then what do we do at 3:00?
Jake: 3点开始就有知识问答和自我介绍
Jake: Starting at 3:00, there will be a quiz and self-introductions
Shure:  那这这些呢
Shure: And these?
Katrina:  这些就是我们要让他们先获得货币
Katrina: These are where we get them to earn currency first
Katrina:  以后我们再推销我们自己的产品
Katrina: Then we sell our products
Katrina:  我其实感觉不确定
Katrina: Actually, I'm not sure
Katrina:  他们到底是E人还是I人
Katrina: If they're E people or I people
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  就万一
Katrina: Just in case
Shure: OK
Shure: Okay
Katrina:  其实可能不会持续很长的时间
Katrina: It might not last very long
Katrina:  自我介绍
Katrina: The self-introductions
Katrina:  这是问了40分钟吧
Katrina: It's about 40 minutes, right?
Katrina:  加自我介绍
Katrina: Plus self-introductions.
Shure:  您说也行
Shure: Sure, that works too.
Jake: 抢答对吧
Jake: Fast response, right?
Katrina:  嗯很快其实
Katrina: Yeah, it's actually quick.
Jake: 对对挺好
Jake: Yes, it's quite good.
Shure:  and知识问答
Shure: And the knowledge quiz...
Katrina: QA
Katrina: QA.
Shure: 嗷
Shure: Oh.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  第3点
Shure: Third point.
Katrina:  然后就每个人介绍自己做的这个
Katrina: Then everyone introduces their work.
Katrina:  然后就跟他们说
Katrina: Then tell them...
Katrina:  他们可以拿他们的货币来
Katrina: They can use their currency to...
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:大家插会电吧
Jake: Let's all plug in.
Jake: 来你们继续聊
Jake: Okay, you guys keep chatting.
Jake: 我给大家发线
Jake: I'll hand out the cables.
Katrina:  40
Katrina: 40.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: Alright, and then?
Jake: 哦你一直插着的
Jake: Oh, you're always plugged in.
Shure:  我一直插着充电宝
Shure: I'm always plugged into a power bank.
Jake: 给我
Jake: Give me.
Jake: 这个是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Katrina:  我我的
Katrina: Mine.
Jake: 好那你插上吧少一个
Jake: Okay, then you plug it in, one less.
Lucia: 我也插上了
Lucia: I'll plug in too.
Shure:  3
Shure: Three.
Katrina: 介绍自己的产品吗
Katrina: Introduce your own product?
Katrina:  每个人
Katrina: Everyone
Shure:  啊3就开始拍卖
Shure: Yeah, then we'll start the auction.
Shure:  怎么说
Shure: What do you think?
Lucia: auction
Lucia: Auction.
Shure:  auction啊AUC
Shure: Auction, right. AUC...
Jake: 你也插一个吧
Jake: You should add one too.
Shure: auction
Shure: Auction.
Alice: 哦谢谢
Alice: Oh, thank you.
Shure:  预计3:40到
Shure: Expected to arrive at 3:40.
Lucia: 一个小时
Lucia: One hour.
Lucia: 或许4点半吧差不多
Lucia: Maybe around 4:30.
Katrina:  你这拍卖
Katrina: This auction...
Katrina:  指的是拍卖他们自己带带的东西
Katrina: Are you auctioning the items they brought?
Katrina:  还是谁来拍卖
Katrina: Or who's doing the auction?
Shure:  自己的和
Shure: Their own items and...
Katrina: 他们自己带的
Katrina: What they brought.
Katrina:  对和我们的
Katrina: Yes, and ours.
Lucia: 和咱们的产品
Lucia: And our products.
Katrina:  那应该不止一个小时吧
Katrina: Then it should take more than an hour.
Lucia: 不止吗那就再长一个半小时
Lucia: More than an hour? Then maybe an hour and a half.
Katrina:  一个半小时差不多
Katrina: An hour and a half, sounds about right.
Katrina:  主要是看他们
Katrina: Mainly depends on them.
Shure: 我们可以细分
Shure: We can divide it.
Shure:  这个是他们自己的部分
Shure: This is their part.
Shure:  这是guest part
Shure: This is the guest part.
Lucia: 这些这些
Lucia: These, these...
Katrina:  这些gets
Katrina: These gets
Katrina:  他们带多少东西
Katrina: How much stuff did they bring?
Lucia: 以及他们是I人还是E人
Lucia: And are they introverts or extroverts?
Katrina:  对这就不确定
Katrina: Yeah, that's uncertain.
Shure:  呃然后还有什么我们的
Shure: Uh, what else do we have?
Shure:  或者我们可以提前来
Shure: Or we can come early
Shure:  活跃一下这个气氛
Shure: To liven up the atmosphere.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  我觉得我们先开始吧
Katrina: I think we should start first.
Shure:  我们先开始
Shure: Let's start first.
Katrina:  3:40到4点半
Katrina: From 3:40 to 4:30.
Katrina:  是我们先开始
Katrina: We start first.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We
Katrina: 每个人
Katrina: Each person
Shure: 会会这么
Shure: Will have about
Katrina: 七八分钟差不多
Katrina: Seven to eight minutes.
Katrina:  七八分钟
Katrina:  那40分钟差不多
Katrina: So that's about 40 minutes.
Katrina:  那就4:20
Katrina: So, around 4:20.
Shure: 4:20吧
Shure: 4:20 then.
Lucia: 或者
Lucia: Or
Lucia: 直接把他们把这段变成我们整体的
Lucia: Just turn this segment into part of our whole event.
Lucia: 一个
Lucia: A
Lucia: 怎么形容一个小续集也行
Lucia: How to describe it, a little sequel.
Lucia: 就是可以让他们先对
Lucia: Just let them,
Lucia: 就是如果对咱们整体的这个手工制品
Lucia: Like for our handmade crafts,
Lucia: 感觉就好比我们是一个商家一样
Lucia: Feel like we are a vendor.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 只不过使用的是这个虚拟货币
Lucia: But using virtual currency.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia: 对然后如果大家玩的比较高兴的
Lucia: Yeah, and if everyone is having fun,
Lucia: 话就后面让他们在自己之间交换
Lucia: Then let them exchange among themselves later.
Katrina:  都行也可以
Katrina: That's fine, we can do that.
Alice:就是我们买了花瓶嘛
Alice: So, we bought a vase.
Katrina:  对对对我买6个
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, I'll buy six.
Alice: 还有在哪呢
Alice: Where else can we get them?
Katrina:  人家都到了
Katrina: They're already here.
Katrina:  但是这花可以让他们自己插
Katrina: But they can arrange the flowers themselves.
Alice: 就是现在不是行花吗
Alice: So, aren't the flowers waking up now?
Alice: 嗯就是
Alice: Yeah, they are.
Katrina:  我的意思是
Katrina: What I mean is...
Katrina:  可以大家自己搭配自己挑嘛
Katrina: Everyone can pick and arrange their own.
Alice: 哦你的意思是
Alice: Oh, you mean...
Katrina: 六六个瓶子吗
Katrina: Six bottles?
Katrina:  然后多的就放这种公共的
Katrina: And the extras will go in a communal vase.
Katrina:  刚才还有花瓶啥的
Katrina: There were vases earlier.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:先醒醒他吧
Alice: Let's wake them up first.
Jake: 我们的食品环节吃饭环下午茶环节
Alice: Our food segment, lunch, and afternoon tea.
Jake: 在什么地方
Jake: Where is it?
Shure:  啊要有一直有一个酒保在那边
Shure: Ah, there should always be a bartender there.
Katrina:  哈哈哈一直有一个酒保
Shure: Hahaha, always a bartender.
Jake: 那酒保在什么位置呢
Jake: Where's the bartender?
Katrina:  我感觉就外面这里已经很好了
Katrina: I think outside here is good.
Jake: 那调酒是在外面
Jake: So, the mixing is outside?
Katrina:  但是但是但是我喝酒
Jake: But, but, but I drink...
Lucia: 调酒是在这个台子上调
Lucia: The mixing is done on this table.
Jake: 也可以啊在室内然后如果有人在这
Jake: Sure, indoors is fine, and if someone is here...
Shure: 就在这
Shure: Just here.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 对刚才那表演就是待在外面的
Lucia: The performance earlier was outside.
Lucia: 玻璃就可以看到
Lucia: You can see through the glass.
Lucia: 调酒师在里面
Lucia: The bartender is inside.
Lucia: 哇好高级啊
Lucia: Wow, it's so fancy.
Jake:对是是
Jake: Yeah, it is.
Lucia: 来来一点打光
Lucia: Let's add some lighting.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 对我们还有这个影棚灯
Lucia: Right, we still have this studio light
Lucia: 虽然这个我们是就一个
Lucia: Although we only have one
Lucia: 一个灯吗
Lucia: Just one light, right?
Jake: 没有四个啊
Jake: No, there are four
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay
Jake: 现在还没装晚一会装一下
Jake: We haven't set them up yet, we'll do it later
Katrina:  那那下午茶时间要不要弄到4:20之后
Katrina: So, should we move the tea time to after 4:20?
Katrina:  要不然插在哪个地方
Katrina: Otherwise, where do we fit it?
Shure: 可以大家边吃边干嘛
Shure: We could eat while we work
Lucia: 就我觉得4:20之后就可以
Lucia: I think after 4:20 is fine
Lucia: 因为一般来说
Lucia: Because usually
Lucia: 下午茶就是3点到5点这个时间段
Lucia: Tea time is between 3 and 5
Jake: 就可能我们一一部分人
Jake: So maybe some of us
Jake: 还是我们先做好
Jake: Should we prepare first?
Jake: 我们可以先做好吗
Jake: Can we prepare first?
什么
Jake:就是那些
Jake: I mean those
Alice:甜品
Tasha:  可以啊
Tasha: Sure
Jake:可以先做好
Jake: We can prepare first
Katrina:  哎那就是反正他他他的是种子片
Katrina: Well, anyway, his is the seed film
Katrina:  就在3:40-4:20介绍
Katrina: Introduce it between 3:40-4:20
Katrina:  然后他作为我们几个的压轴
Katrina: And then he will be the finale for us
Katrina:  然后介绍完了以后大家可以分发一下
Katrina: After the introduction, everyone can distribute
Katrina:  尝一下他的那个甜品
Katrina: And taste his desserts
Alice: 甜品摆台吗
Alice: Dessert presentation?
Katrina:  也有钱了嘛
Katrina: We have the money, right
Tasha: 摆台吗
Tasha: Presentation?
Alice:摆台吗
Jake: 摆什么甜品摆
Jake: What dessert presentation?
Lucia: 就是 下午茶
Lucia: It's just afternoon tea
Alice:就是下午茶，啊
Alice: The afternoon tower.
Alice:啊 啊啊
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 看一下就觉得好看
Tasha: 嗯好的
Tasha: Yeah, sure.
Tasha: 那就是甜品台做一次要800-1,000呢
Tasha: So, making a dessert table costs about 800 to 1,000.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Shure:  怎么杨老板突然空手了
Shure: Why is Jake suddenly empty-handed?
Shure:  应该是哈哈哈
Shure: It should be, hahaha.
Jake: 可以可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Tasha: 没有只是买个甜品台架子
Tasha: No, just buying a dessert table frame.
Jake: 架子1,000是吧
Jake: The frame is 1,000, right?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Jake:那是什么
Jake: What is it?
Alice: 总共的吧
Alice: The total, I guess.
Jake: 总共500-1,000
Jake: Total 500 to 1,000.
Tasha: 就是你你去做的话
Tasha: If you make it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 去外面吗
Shure: Outside?
Alice:Ye
Alice:因为不放进去的话
Alice: Because if you don't put it in,
Alice:就是水流声太大了所以我放进去了
Alice: The water sound is too loud, so I put it in.
Katrina:  可能就在那种环境下
Katrina: Maybe in that kind of environment,
Katrina:  然后就愿意讲
Katrina: They are willing to talk.
Katrina:  但是我们这种刚过来
Katrina: But for us who just arrived,
Katrina:  他们可能不太愿意讲故事
Katrina: They might not be willing to share stories.
Katrina:  所以改成自我介绍还挺好
Katrina: So, changing to self-introduction is good.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then,
Katrina:  如果说要讲故事或获金币这个环节
Katrina: If we have a story-telling or gold-earning session,
Katrina:  我觉得可以弄到偏晚上1点
Katrina: I think it can be done around 1 am,
Katrina:  大家已经熟了一点
Katrina: When everyone is more familiar.
Katrina:  再加上晚上比较感性
Katrina: Plus, at night people are more sentimental.
Katrina:  可以带着一点自己的故事过来
Katrina: They can bring their own stories.
Katrina:  然后那
Katrina: And then,
Katrina:  那就5点
Katrina: Then it's 5 o'clock.
Katrina:  是他们介绍完他们的pass
Katrina: They finished introducing their pass
Katrina:  然后5点到6点就吃烧烤调酒这种吗
Katrina: Then from 5 to 6, we can have BBQ and cocktails, right?
Katrina:  其实他并不会完全严格的按照这个
Katrina: Actually, he won't strictly follow this schedule
Jake: 对所以可以搞个5点到6点的区间
Jake: Yeah, so we can have a range from 5 to 6
Shure:  反正开饭dinner
Shure: Anyway, dinner starts
Shure:  在5点半之后
Shure: After 5:30
Shure:  5点半左右嗯
Shure: Around 5:30, yeah
Jake: 打比赛
Jake: Competition
Jake: a bow
Jake: A bow
Jake: 第一个披萨
Jake: The first pizza
Katrina:  第一个披萨还有BBQ
Katrina: The first pizza and BBQ
Shure:  bbq
Shure: BBQ
Katrina:  那调酒的话是属于贯穿始终
Katrina: And cocktails will be available throughout
Shure:  对就像甜品和
Shure: Yeah, just like desserts and
Katrina:  甜品就是
Katrina: Desserts are
Katrina:  他们入场的时候是ert吧
Katrina: When they enter, it's ert, right?
Shure:  嗯还是SS
Shure: Hmm, or SS
Shure:  什么SSWS乘2
Shure: Something like SSWS times 2
Katrina:  哦你说甜品啊
Katrina: Oh, you mean desserts
Shure:  and
Shure: And
Katrina:  那晚上就还剩啥
Katrina: So, what's left for the evening?
Katrina:  我想想还剩我们的节目
Katrina: Let me think, we still have our program
Jake: 对我们有
Jake: Yeah, we have
Katrina:  然后也不能弄太晚
Katrina: And it can't be too late
Katrina:  他们回去的话要两个小时
Katrina: They need two hours to get back
Katrina:  嗯那我们就定个结束时间
Katrina: Hmm, let's set an end time
Jake: 8点可以贯彻失重
Jake: 8 o'clock can work
Katrina:  2点半到8点差不多了
Katrina: From 2:30 to 8, that's about right
Katrina:  忙够呛了对
Katrina: Pretty busy, yeah
Katrina:  跟戴娜差不多
Katrina: Just like with Dana
Katrina:  到6点半
Katrina: Until 6:30
Katrina:  然后还有一个半小时就是表演
Katrina: Then we have an hour and a half for the performance
Katrina:  表演节目
Katrina: The performance
Katrina:  能让他们也准备点节目吗
Katrina: Can we have them prepare some acts too?
Katrina:  有没有那种擅长唱歌的
Katrina: Are there any good singers?
Shure:  可以反正我们又挖吉他
Shure: Sure, we can bring out the guitar
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah
Katrina:  啊唱唱歌跳跳舞
Katrina: Ah, some singing and dancing
Jake: 对时间太长了
Jake: Yeah, if it’s too long
Lucia: 来一个大家一起卡拉OK的环节吧
Lucia: How about a karaoke session for everyone?
Katrina:  哪个时间太长
Katrina: Which time is too long?
Jake: 不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我我我是说中间可能有一个小时
Jake: I-I-I mean there might be an hour in between.
Jake: 我们要传数据
Jake: We need to transfer the data.
Jake: 你们的眼睛
Jake: Your eyes...
Katrina:  传数据让他们自己逛逛我们的世界
Katrina: Transfer the data and let them explore our world.
Katrina:  然后喝点酒
Katrina: And then have some drinks.
Katrina:  传数据的时候带大家唱唱歌好了
Katrina: While transferring the data, we can sing some songs.
Shure:  free time
Shure: Free time.
Alice: 在这放一个小电影或者干嘛的
Alice: We can play a short movie or something.
Shure: 小电影
Shure: A short movie.
Alice:这个可以用一下
Alice: We can use that.
Jake: 中间中间空一个小时差大概
Jake: Leave an hour gap in between roughly.
Shure:  对当时还说那个什么什么纪录片
Jake:就3点到 6点
Katrina:  那就是那个5点结束之后呗
Katrina: So that's after it ends at 5 PM, right?
Jake: 对啊他家吃披萨时候咱就不拍了吧
Jake: Yes, we won't film while they're having pizza at his place.
Alice:呵呵
Jake: 行甜品是什么
Jake: Okay, what's the dessert?
Tasha: 也可以哪个时间段吃甜品
Tasha: We can have dessert during any time slot.
Katrina:  甜品是你就是我
Katrina: Dessert is you, it's me.
Katrina:  host host part就是他们一二环节
Katrina: The host part is their first or second section.
Katrina:  然后就是刚好这个part结束了
Katrina: And then this part just ends nicely.
Katrina:  以后大家就可以尝你的甜品
Katrina: After that, everyone can try your dessert.
Katrina:  4:20 对
Katrina: At 4:20, yes.
Katrina:  就是你压轴
Katrina: You're the finale.
Katrina:  哈哈你介绍你的种子片和你的甜品
Katrina: Haha, you introduce your seeds and your dessert.
Katrina:  我们介绍我们自己做的种子
Katrina: We introduce the seeds we made ourselves.
Jake: 可以嗯
Jake: Alright, yeah.
Jake: 3点到5点两个小时够
Jake: Two hours from 3 PM to 5 PM is enough.
Jake: 挺好大概从早上就要开始准备
Jake: Pretty good, we need to start preparing from the morning.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Katrina:  不是你怎么听到
Katrina: How did you hear that?
Katrina:  你不是住一楼吗
Katrina: Don't you live on the first floor?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  因为咱俩应该就是差不多上上下这种
Shure: Because we're almost right above and below each other.
Shure:  啊你那个跟我是一样的
Shure: Ah, yours is the same as mine.
Shure:  不过也正常
Shure: But it's normal.
Lucia: 我我我本科舍友回我早晨定的闹铃
Lucia: My undergraduate roommate woke up to my alarm in the morning.
Lucia: 我舍友都醒了
Lucia: My roommate was awake.
Lucia: 我自己还没醒自己就听不见
Lucia: I hadn't woken up myself and didn't hear it.
Shure:  嗯明天定三个
Shure: Hmm, let's set three for tomorrow.
Katrina:  那就差不多想想啊
Katrina: That sounds about right, let's think about it.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 所以那一天的甜品是要当天做
Jake: So, should the dessert be made on the same day?
Jake: 还是可以前一天做
Jake: Or can it be made the day before?
Tasha: 有的需要冷藏的会前一天做
Tasha: Some that need refrigeration can be made the day before.
Tasha: 比如提拉米苏
Tasha: Like Tiramisu.
Katrina:  哎其实像那种
Katrina: Oh, actually for things like that...
Katrina:  就是我看他们那种清补凉那种
Katrina: I see they make something like Ching Bo Leung...
Katrina:  是不是就买点椰奶然后做点圆
Katrina: You just need to buy some coconut milk and make some taro balls.
Tasha: 清补凉的话那是不是好调一点啊
Tasha: For Ching Bo Leung, it's easy to prepare, right?
Tasha: 也是前一天做好
Tasha: You can make it the day before too.
Tasha: 然后第二天就直接把原料
Tasha: Then just mix the ingredients the next day.
Tasha: 然后进行一个配就行
Tasha: Use gelatin sheets and coconut milk.
Tasha: 对对对就是用那个吉利丁片和椰奶
Tasha: And you can make it.
Tasha: 就可以做
Tasha: I think...
Tasha: 好像
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina:  我看他们有的那种糖水就是直接椰奶
Katrina: I saw some desserts where they just use coconut milk...
Katrina:  然后加一点水果
Katrina: And add some fruit.
Katrina:  加一点芋圆就行了
Katrina: And some taro balls, that's it.
Katrina:  感觉那样会不会简单一点
Katrina: Wouldn't that be easier?
Katrina:  就不要做成那种冻不起的那种
Katrina: Instead of making it into a jelly that won't set.
Katrina:  就不要用那个什么吉利饮片
Katrina: Just don't use gelatin sheets.
Tasha: 那清不了好吃吗
Tasha: Would that taste good though?
Tasha: 你觉得我觉得随便
Tasha: You think? I don't mind.
Katrina:  就是我感觉会不会简单一点那种吗
Katrina: I just think it might be simpler that way.
Tasha: 他说不要液体不要固体的啊
Tasha: They said no liquid, no solid, right?
Katrina:  就是直接就像那种水牛奶一样的
Katrina: Just like liquid coconut milk.
Katrina:  因为我自己经常喝的糖水
Katrina: I often drink sweet soups like that.
Katrina:  我看他们就是一点椰奶啊
Katrina: They just add a bit of coconut milk...
Katrina:  然后芒果然后一些那个红豆
Katrina: And some mango, and some red beans.
Katrina:  就就这样配就很快
Katrina: Mix it up and it's ready quickly.
Katrina:  嗯就是芋圆可能要熬一下
Katrina: Hmm, the taro balls might need to be boiled.
Katrina:  椰果呢都能现买耶
Katrina: But you can buy the coconut jelly.
Katrina:  随便看你看你吧
Katrina: Whatever, up to you.
Katrina:  你说什么就是什么
Katrina: Whatever you say goes.
Alice: 你准备了芋圆的东西吗
Tasha: 我我
Tasha: Taro balls, I...
Tasha: 我没有买芋圆材料
Tasha: I didn't buy the ingredients for taro balls.
Katrina:  芋圆是不是可以直接买
Katrina: Can we just buy taro balls directly?
Katrina:  芋圆也有成品吧
Katrina: They sell ready-made taro balls, right?
Lucia: 嗯对直接买成品
Lucia: Yeah, you can just buy the ready-made ones.
Katrina:  那我看看
Katrina: Let me check.
Katrina:  4:20介绍完以后
Katrina: After the introduction at 4:20,
Katrina:  要有一个品尝甜品的时间
Katrina: We should have some time to taste the desserts.
Katrina:  那是不是要到4点
Katrina: So it should be around 4 o'clock, right?
Katrina:  4:35开始
Katrina: Start at 4:35.
Katrina:  但是我到5点多
Katrina: But by the time it's past 5,
Katrina:  然后就开始吃晚饭晚饭
Katrina: Then we start having dinner.
Katrina:  就是gas part之后我们就收眼镜传数据
Katrina: After the gas part, we'll collect the glasses and transfer the data.
Jake: 对对对然后吃饭就不录
Jake: Right, right, and we won't record during dinner.
Jake: 吃饭不录
Jake: No recording during dinner.
Jake: 那那晚饭是自己做吗
Jake: So, are we cooking dinner ourselves?
Katrina:  晚饭就那个点披萨嘛
Katrina: Dinner will be pizza,
Katrina:  然后一些烧烤
Katrina: And some barbecue.
Jake: 烧烤也不能录烧烤把
Jake: We can't record the barbecue either, right?
Jake: 眼镜给收
Jake: Collect the glasses.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Katrina:  没事刚好那那一个小时
Katrina: No worries, just transfer the data for an hour,
Katrina:  那你就传数据第一个披萨得了
Katrina: And then you can have the first pizza.
Jake: 对对barbecue
Jake: Yeah, and the barbecue.
Shure:  再说
Shure: We'll see.
Shure:  barbecue可以咱们咱们这两天自个吃
Shure: We can do the barbecue ourselves over the next couple of days.
Jake: 哈哈哈什么东西
Jake: Haha, what are you talking about?
Jake: 芭比q自己试试
Jake: Try the BBQ yourself.
Alice: 那个是烧烤炉吗
Lucia: 是的是的
Lucia: Yeah, it is.
Alice: 哦还挺大
Alice: Oh, it's pretty big.
Alice: 对
Alice: Right.
Shure:  然后人太多的话
Shure: And if there are too many people,
Shure:  芭比q真的不好不好玩
Shure: BBQ isn't that fun.
Alice: 特别慢对
Alice: It's really slow, yeah.
Jake: 那就不要芭比q
Jake: Then let's not do BBQ.
Jake: 或者给他整两串得了
Jake: Or just make a couple of skewers for the sake of it.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 意思意思
Katrina: Just for the sake of it.
Jake: 那就是意思
Jake: Exactly.
Jake: 哈哈哈那是我自己烤的
Jake: Haha, I grilled it myself.
Lucia: 点到点进来然后就自己烤的
Lucia: Order it, then come in and grill it yourself.
Lucia: 说是烤的
Lucia: They say it's grilled.
Shure:  对菜咱们只买菜然后热一下
Shure: Yeah, we just buy the food and heat it up a bit.
Shure:  哇哈哈哈好妙啊
Shure: Hahaha, that's brilliant.
Jake: 哈哈挺好看的
Jake: Haha, it looks pretty good.
Lucia: 有西餐厅那种圆的那样罩住
Lucia: It's like those round covers in Western restaurants.
Lucia: 要不然话
Lucia: Otherwise,
Lucia: 大家就会发现
Lucia: people will find out
Lucia: 你这个拿出来的时候
Lucia: when you take it out,
Lucia: 就已经是烤好的了哦
Lucia: it's already grilled.
Lucia: 然后就这样挡一下
Lucia: Then just cover it a bit,
Lucia: 然后放在炉上烤一烤
Lucia: and put it on the stove to grill.
Lucia: 说是刚烤的
Lucia: Say it's freshly grilled.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是是是
Lucia: Hahaha, yes, yes.
Shure:  太天才了
Shure: That's genius.
Jake: 我们对一分钟考好
Jake: We can grill it in a minute.
Katrina:  那就我们的那个活动就6点半到8点
Katrina: So our event will be from 6:30 to 8:00.
Katrina:  节目唱唱歌跳舞
Katrina: Singing and dancing programs.
Katrina:  一个半小时够了再长弄不下去了
Katrina: An hour and a half is enough, any longer and it won't work.
Alice:这是谁的水
Alice: Whose water is this?
Katrina:  free time对大家可以表演一个半小时
Katrina: Free time, everyone can perform for an hour and a half.
Shure:  然后我们可以auction拆出来也行
Shure: Then we can auction it off too.
Shure:  就是比如说没进行完有的人没拍
Shure: Like, if someone didn't get to bid,
Shure:  拍完然后啊可以继续想分享
Shure: after the bid, they can continue if they want to share.
Katrina:  接着大家自由交换也行也行
Katrina: Then everyone can freely exchange, that's fine too.
Jake: 嗯反正一般等家务已经有了
Jake: Hmm, anyway, we usually have house chores by then.
Lucia: 那就是5点半开饭然后6点半我要走了
Lucia: So we eat at 5:30, and then I have to leave at 6:30.
Jake:我们之前让GPT出了几个plan
Jake:比如环保版
Jake:比你说你画我猜
Lucia: 啊这个小游戏呢
Jake:参与者分组
Jake:每组选择一个环保词汇
Jake:如太阳能
Jake:零废弃
Katrina: 哎这个也很不错
Shure: 就这种特别抽象的
Shure: 但是不好画
Shure: 只能画我不能描述
Jake:画画不能说话了
Katrina: 那就设置在晚上
Jake:可以
Katrina: 下午的时间不是很多
Katrina: 下午3点开始到5点半就两个半小时
Katrina: 介绍介绍
Katrina: 逛一逛就差不多了
Jake:还有一个更离谱的
Jake:在沙盘或沙地中
Jake:隐藏一些微型塑料颗粒
Jake:参与者使用镊子和放大镜
Jake:在规定时间内尽可能找出镊子
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Shure: 这有点难了
Jake:这个游戏
Jake:可以让大家直观的认识到
Jake:微塑料污染的隐蔽性
Jake:哈哈哈狠掉这个
Jake:GDP10万人AI哈哈哈
Jake:要不还我们下午
Jake:下午采购一波
Jake:采购一波
Shure: 下午要去采购是吗
Alice:谢谢
Jake:再看一下
Jake:我们其实不用
Jake:但是也看一下
Lucia: 停住了
Jake:没事
Jake:我们其实剩下的一个人就行
Jake:但是就转一圈比较稳
Katrina: 这东西很好看
Shure: 哦你们看那个你想活出怎样的人生了吗？
Katrina:  看了没看懂后来看解析了
Katrina: 回来看解析
Katrina: 应该要先看解析再去看
Alice:它只有5%的电
Alice:正充着电
Alice:它不会充的没用的快吧
Shure: 不要保持太紧就可以
Katrina: 那就就差不多敲定了
Jake:差不多了
Jake:那我们看看要准备什么吧这一
Katrina: 就各自买各自的材料然后
Katrina: 然后要有音响和话筒
Katrina: 如果要唱的
Katrina: 哦你本来就乐队的是吗
Jake:可以把乐队同学弄来
Katrina: 我们当时就也总是为乐队同学带音响
Shure: 这这算商演吗
Jake:商演商演
Jake:学术商演
Alice:哈哈哈
Jake:在学术会议上面商演
Jake:演唱会算什么
Jake:你们接过这种活吗
Shure: 之前邀邀请过
Shure: 但是哦没去
Jake:没去
Shure: 有点太尴尬了
Jake:下面人来看pose了
Jake:然后一个人
Shure: 对啊多尬呀我靠
Katrina: 他那个呃我们买了什么
Katrina: 支架和小桌子吗
Jake:嗯我们要不看看快递
Jake:或者我们到处看一看吧
Jake:我们
Jake:因为这个房间我们可能也要收拾收拾
Jake:装饰装饰
Katrina: 哦那我们是不是
Katrina: 如果你要世界地球日会主题
Katrina: 要买一点贴画呀
Jake:对对对是
Jake:但这个墙不能贴
Jake:我们也得想想办法
Katrina: 有那种无痕贴的挂钩
Jake:就是他就不能贴这种墙
Katrina: 我找我姐结婚的时候
Katrina: 他们就是那种贴的
Katrina: 就是酒店贴的
Katrina: 可以撕下来就完全无痕
Jake:OK如果很稳妥的话可以
Jake:不然的话赔钱
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake:就是惨了
Katrina: 然后还有就是我们每个人的东西的话
Katrina: 他的甜品和自己的甜品
Katrina: 占到我们每个人的东西
Katrina: 是不是也要有装
Katrina: 桌子摆开
Jake:嗯可以
Katrina: 因为那一天
Shure: 可以去宜家采购
Jake:哈哈哈过分
Katrina: 直接给别墅主人进行家具
Alice:一个够吗
Alice:还是要多买两个
Katrina: 对一个是
Katrina: 就是多少人可以一起玩
Shure: 大概就一个人一起玩
Lucia: 三个人应该也行
Lucia: 再多
Shure: 其实买3个差不多
Jake:我们要不玩一下
Jake:怎么玩呢
Alice:就直接往里面拼
Lucia: 试验一下
Shure: 我们这些这些都得试验一遍
Shure: 就是甜饼我也得先先试一遍
Katrina: 彩排
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice:这是一个支架的就不用管他了
Shure: 毕竟其实这个比点外卖会便宜一些
Tasha: 什么会比点外卖便宜
Shure: 就是比如说自己搞顿烧烤
Shure: 比点一桌的烧烤烤串
Shure: 肯定会便宜
Jake:那是这烧烤卖的可贵了一根
Shure: 一根串四五块钱
Alice: 挺多
Jake:哦看起来很难拼啊
Alice:确实不太好拼
Alice:比较费时间可能
Tasha: 怎么拼啊
Jake:只把它给拼成一个圆啊
Jake:也要fit进去边缘
Shure: 这种弧形都应该在边
Jake:他有可能骗你的吧
Jake:会有可能吧
Tasha: 哎你这个明显就不在边边
Tasha: 你这个不对不对
Jake:毫无头绪
Jake:一个都没有
Lucia: 这个应该是在边边的
Lucia: 这个
Jake:这个我不能
Jake:找不到了
Lucia: 这个好像也能贴
Alice:这个也是吗
Lucia: 不完全
Jake:他是一定会
Jake:完全还是他
Alice:我得看看
Katrina: 别让大家熟悉起来哦
Katrina: 这几个人坐在一起
Jake:有那种特别大的
Alice:没有很大的
Alice:就是这
Lucia: 很有可能
Shure: 哎呦是吧
Shure: 屌的嘞哈哈哈
Lucia: 感觉应该是看起来很
Lucia: 就是密合程度是比较高的
Lucia: 是的那这个就是
Tasha: 天才三位天才
Shure: 洒洒水啊
Shure: 这不两分钟搞定
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 这里是缺一个
Shure: 啊
Alice:哦不是完全拼合的
Alice:还是有一点点缝缝的
Alice:看一下答案吗
Shure: 不是不要
Alice:就是你也记不住啊
Jake:我能拼出来
Shure: 哈哈哈我们看答案
Shure: 开什么玩笑
Lucia: 我觉得这个参与度还是很高的
Alice:反正你也记不住
Alice:哈哈哈
Tasha: 我刚看到了跟他很像的在这里
Tasha: 嗯
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 这俩看起来是颜色
Jake:它不是严丝合缝的
Katrina: 没有严丝合缝就很好找啊
Jake:他有可能有很多解法
Jake: 毫无头绪
Jake:这可能就啥也没有啊
Jake:逗你玩哈哈哈
Tasha: 我觉得都没有一圈怎么回事
Jake:对啊他面积都不够
Jake:我们要不直接往里面放吧
Alice:哈哈哈
Jake:不是不是不是往里面放
Lucia: 面积可能还是差不多的吧
Lucia: 看起来就是这还有一些就感觉
Tasha:  哦我靠
Lucia: 好抽象啊
Lucia: So abstract
Jake: 大嘴鸟
Jake: A toucan
Jake: 这个也很抽象
Jake: This is also very abstract
Jake: 谁家牛长这样
Jake: Whose cow looks like this?
Shure:  野牛啊水牛
Shure: A wild buffalo or a water buffalo
Jake: 那水牛为什么下面会长稻草
Jake: Then why does the water buffalo have straw growing underneath it?
Alice: 他站在草上
Alice: It's standing on the grass
Shure:  毛很长这个这个
Shure: Its fur is long, this, this
Lucia: 是不是他这一边
Lucia: Is it this side?
Lucia: 是哎对
Lucia: Yes, it is
Shure:  他叫牦牛
Shure: It's called a yak
Shure:  对这个很妙
Shure: Yes, this is amazing
Jake: 嗯这个太妙了
Jake: Hmm, this is incredible
Lucia: 然后既然是这一边的话
Jake: And since it's this side
Lucia: 那这里应该有一个能放的东西
Lucia: There should be something to place here
Alice: 尖尖的
Alice: Something pointy
Lucia: 好像不是耶
Lucia: It doesn't seem to be
Shure:  不是CPU干烧了
Shure:  AI快给我一个解法
Shure: AI, give me a solution quickly
Jake: 大家一直在看时间
Jake: Everyone is watching the time
Jake: 看秒表这个数据
Jake: Checking the stopwatch data
Katrina:  看这个书为了干啥
Katrina: What's the point of looking at this book?
Katrina:  为了同步
Katrina: For synchronization
Jake: 回头就是在某一个帧上面把时间写上
Jake: Later, we just need to write the time on a specific frame
Jake: 哦明白了
Jake: Oh, got it
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: So difficult
Jake: 这个会在边上吗
Jake: Will this be on the edge?
Jake: 还有没有边了
Jake: Is there any edge left?
Lucia: 这个边怎么给人一种不太够的感觉
Lucia: Why does this edge feel a bit insufficient?
Alice: 他这不是严丝合缝
Alice: 有的是差不多的那种
Alice: Some are almost similar
Alice: 嗯这回是比较不太像
Alice: Hmm, this time it doesn't quite match
Jake: 要不还是全放进去吧
Jake: How about we just put everything in?
Jake: 哈哈全放进去
Jake: Haha, put everything in
Jake: 先看一看他乱拼的话差多少
Jake: Let's see how much it deviates if we just randomly piece it together
Tasha: 这只鸟好占位
Tasha: This bird takes up so much space
Katrina:  所有的都可以放进去
Katrina: Everything can be placed
Alice:对
Jake: 刚刚就是这么拿出来的
Jake: That’s how it was just taken out.
Shure:  比那个不是大只的哦
Shure: Isn't that one bigger though?
Alice:不是，他是外面
Jake: 那就塞个你
Jake: Then just stuff it in.
Tasha: 你塞不进去换一个
Tasha: If you can't fit it, use a different one.
Tasha: 你也塞不进去
Tasha: You can't fit it either.
Katrina:  我们塞他
Katrina: We'll stuff him.
Alice: 这啥这是刺猬吗
Alice: 哈哈可以
Alice: Haha, yes.
Tasha: 他肯定就在这了
Tasha: He must be here.
Lucia: 哦就是我以为他是太阳
Alice:胯下，哈
Tasha: 看哈哈哈像不像太阳
Lucia: 我觉得这个太阳应该很好找到对应的
Lucia: I think this sun should be easy to match.
Lucia: 就因为他这里有很多的刺
Lucia: Because it has a lot of spikes here.
Lucia: 所以这边我觉得这个是这个特别像耶
Lucia: So I think this one looks really similar.
Jake: 哇这个这个太严格了吧
Jake: Wow, this is too strict.
Jake: 耶我去
Jake: Yeah, seriously.
Jake: 这太严格了
Jake: This is too strict.
Jake: 如果都是这种严格程度的话
Jake: If everything is this strict,
Jake: 那就好找了
Jake: Then it’ll be easy to find.
Alice:这就好找了啊
Lucia: 胜利又顺利找到一个
Alice: 谁没家
Alice:他们没有
Shure:  如今你四海为家
Tasha: 怎么办还有这么多人没有家
Tasha: What about the many people who are homeless?
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  回家回回家
Shure: Go home, go go home.
Shure:  回家是最好的礼物
Shure: Going home is the best gift.
Jake: 放BGM吧
Jake: Play the BGM.
Jake: 要不BGM再继续进去
Jake: Or should we let the BGM continue?
Shure:  这时候应该放这个怎么办
Shure: Now we should play this, what do we do?
Alice: 是不是标注一下
Alice: Should we annotate it?
Alice: 为什么这时候要放这个
Alice: Why play this now?
Alice: BGM
Tasha: 嗯是吧
Tasha: Yeah, right?
Jake: 嗯很难很难说
Jake: Hmm, it's hard to say.
Jake: 好吧不是有可能
Jake: Okay, maybe not.
Lucia: 能让AI把这些轮廓都扫描一下
Lucia: Can we scan all these outlines with AI?
Lucia: 然后让他帮忙拼吗
Lucia: And have it help us piece them together?
Lucia: 嗯试试
Lucia: Hmm, give it a try.
Alice: 无限次试
Alice: Try unlimited times.
Alice: 对反正他算的快
Alice: Yeah, it calculates fast anyway.
Lucia: 对就是应该有这种类似的软件吧
Lucia: Yeah, there should be some kind of software like this.
Lucia: 不然就是那种乐高都是怎么设计的
Lucia: Otherwise, how do they design those Lego sets?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 动物世界
Alice: Animal world.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Tasha: 哈哈哈哎
Tasha: Hahaha, yeah.
Lucia: 很像很像
Lucia: Very similar, very similar.
Lucia: 应该是的
Lucia: It should be.
Lucia: 嗯好厉害
Lucia: Hmm, really impressive.
Tasha: 他们俩捆绑了
Tasha: They tied them together.
Tasha: 对就是把
Tasha: Yeah, like that.
Lucia: 只要把那
Lucia: As long as...
Lucia: 个能合上的都放在一起先
Lucia: We put the ones that can be closed together first.
Lucia: 然后再看他们具体是个怎么回事把
Lucia: Then see what exactly is going on with them.
Tasha: 把不对的拿出来对对
Tasha: Take out the ones that don't fit, right.
Alice: 他俩是不是
Alice: Are they...
Lucia: 这个肯定在边上
Lucia: 所以这个也可以这样放一下
Alice: 他三
Lucia: 但是这他这个这么明显
Lucia: But this one is so obvious.
Alice: 像不像
Lucia: 应该会有一个
Lucia: There should be one...
Alice: 他俩像不像一家的
Alice: 感觉是一家的
Tasha: 他就没有那么一家他
Tasha: He doesn't look as much like family.
Tasha: 这样子吧
Alice: 就没有那么严丝合缝的
Tasha: 中间能不能再塞一条东西这个
Tasha: Can we fit something in the middle here?
Lucia: 是不是有点像啊
Lucia: Doesn't it look a bit like it?
Jake: 反过来不至于
Jake: Not really when you flip it.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 或者在这里面谁是条条的
Alice: Or who here is stripy?
Tasha: 他他不一定对
Tasha: He might not be right.
Tasha: 他拿走这这些小家伙都不对
Tasha: He took away all the little ones that are wrong.
Tasha: 这个有有谁是长成这样的
Tasha: Who looks like this?
Tasha: 这样吗可以这个样子哦
Tasha: Like this? Oh, okay.
Shure:  在中间留着一点
Shure: Leave a bit in the middle.
Shure:  然后这样哦
Shure: And then like this, oh.
Lucia: 有道理就可以
Lucia: Makes sense, that's fine.
Lucia: 看这个和这两边感觉就比较哎
Lucia: See, this and both sides feel like, well...
Tasha: 找刚刚找的那个呢
Tasha: Where's the one we were just looking for?
Tasha: 哦不是
Tasha: Oh, it's not.
Tasha: 我还找了一个呢
Tasha: I found another one.
Alice: 我把它拆了
Alice: 拆成他俩了
Alice: You took it apart into two?
Alice: 就你刚刚说的是这个吧
Tasha: 他又在上去存疑
Tasha: He went back up again to check.
Lucia: 完了咱这么长时间都没拼出来
Alice: We couldn't figure it out in such a long time.
Alice: 他两像吗
Lucia: 要是放到下午大家拼可能也拼不出来
Lucia: Even if we try in the afternoon, we might not figure it out.
Katrina:  让他们玩一下午吧对
Katrina: Let them play all afternoon, right?
Katrina:  这拼出来了给多少金币
Katrina: How many coins do we get if we solve it?
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha: 这个为什么在摸他的屁股
Tasha: Why is this one touching his butt?
Tasha: 然后这个蹲在他的屁股上
Tasha: And this one is squatting on his butt.
Tasha: 哈哈哈你是来拉屎的吧
Tasha: Hahaha, are you here to poop?
Tasha: 哈哈哈真的是这样放的吗
Tasha: Hahaha, is it really supposed to be placed like this?
Tasha: 哈哈也可能不是
Tasha: Haha, maybe not.
Shure:  这绝对不是
Shure: Definitely not.
Shure:  太变态了
Shure: That's too weird.
Tasha: 好了只有目前这些是确定的
Tasha: Alright, for now, these are the only ones we're sure about.
Lucia: 好难啊
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 他的这个脚肯定
Alice: His foot for sure...
Lucia: 吗不太可能
Shure:  这个脚肯定插到谁的屁股里
Shure: This foot is definitely going up someone's butt.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 这个在这的
Tasha: It's right here.
Alice:不太像
Alice: 他揭着他的屁股好
Alice: He's revealing his butt.
Alice: 好尴尬
Alice: So awkward.
Tasha: 刚刚谁说他是土地公公的
Tasha: Who just said he was the Earth God?
Alice: 哎这两个是不是可以在一起块
Alice: Hey, can these two be together?
Lucia: 好了哇
Lucia: Alright then.
Alice:好 又来一个
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: 感觉胜利在望了
Lucia: Feels like victory is in sight.
Tasha: 三人游戏
Tasha: Three-person game.
Jake: 三人游戏
Jake: Three-person game.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Alright,
Jake: 这是个什么
Lucia: 这是个猴子吧
Lucia: 好像哦是的
Alice: 这样也挺挺搭的
Jake: 像吗
Jake: 一般像吧
Jake: It kind of looks like it.
Tasha: 亚班吧
Jake:有可能吧
Alice:像吗，一般像
Jake: 一般像
Jake: Does it look like it? It generally does.
Tasha: 两个细长条形的
Tasha: Two long, slender shapes.
Jake: 这片头多久啊
Jake: How long is this intro?
Jake: 几分钟刚刚的
Jake: Just a few minutes.
Jake: 动物世界4分32秒
Jake: Animal World, 4 minutes 32 seconds.
Shure:  哈哈什么东西
Shure: Haha, what is that?
Jake: 刚刚那个动物世界
Jake: Just now, that Animal World.
Jake: 4分32秒已经悄悄的过去了
Jake: 4 minutes and 32 seconds have quietly passed.
Tasha: 才过去4分钟吗
Tasha: Only 4 minutes passed?
Tasha: 嗯哈哈
Tasha: Hmm, haha.
Jake: 还好还好
Jake: It's alright, it's alright.
Lucia: 怎么觉得这个弧形边完全找不全对
Lucia: Why do I feel like this curved edge is completely off?
Tasha: 所以
Tasha: So...
Tasha: 这个算是
Alice:反了
Alice: 是吧哎
Alice: Right?
Alice: 反了吧没反
Alice: Flipped or not flipped?
Alice: 嗯就这颜色
Alice: Hmm, just this color.
Tasha: 我不想
Tasha: I don't want to.
Tasha: 哎你刚不是把那个放在一起了吗
Tasha: Hey, didn't you just put that together?
Alice: 疑似
Alice: Suspected.
Alice: 也不想
Alice: I don't want to either.
Lucia: 他到底是哪一边
Lucia: Which side is it really?
Alice: 他是来迷惑你的
Alice: He's here to confuse you.
Lucia: 感觉两个好像都可以
Lucia: It feels like both sides could work.
Alice: 不太像这么大啊
Tasha: It doesn't quite look that big.
Shure:  血压高了怎么办
Shure: What if my blood pressure goes up?
Lucia: 哎会是这样的
Shure: Hey, it could be like this.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm, hmm.
Alice:嗯
Tasha: 这个是在这个边边上吗
Tasha: Is this on the edge here?
Tasha: 这个是在边边上
Tasha: This is on the edge.
Lucia: don't you
Lucia: Don't you...
Alice:应该是这样贴着
Jake: 拆快递吧
Jake: Let's open the package.
Jake: 要不哈哈
Jake: Or not, haha.
Jake: 啊拆快递拆快递拆快递拆快递
Jake: Ah, let's open the package, open the package, open the package.
Katrina:  我去把我的花不行了
Katrina: I'll go get my flowers, they're dying.
Shure:  血压高了
Shure: Blood pressure is high.
Alice: 怎么怎么回事
Alice: What's going on?
Jake: 拆拆一会回来
Jake: Just unbox it, I'll be back in a bit.
Jake: 呃呃就有灵感了
Jake: Uh, uh, then I'll get some inspiration.
Jake: 在哪拆快递
Jake: Where do we unbox the packages?
Jake: 呃那边有一些快递
Jake: Uh, there are some packages over there.
Jake: 然后就过来拆
Jake: Then just come over and unbox them.
Katrina:  我要整一波我的
Katrina: I want to unbox mine too.
Tasha: 我还有在菜鸟驿站的
Jake: 哦我看一下他们
Jake: Hmm, oh, I'll take a look at them.
Katrina:  都是我的都是你的
Katrina: They're all mine, all yours.
Katrina:  这这也是我的哎
Katrina: This, this is also mine, hey.
Katrina:  有剪刀吗有有有
Katrina: Do you have scissors? Yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 这俩脚
Tasha: These two feet...
Alice: 哈哈
Lucia: 好奇怪啊
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Lucia: How could it be?
Katrina:  这买多少个来着
Katrina: How many did you buy again?
Alice: 它会不会是在边边
Alice: 他在边也
Alice: He's at the edge too.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:这样或者这样
Lucia: 这个有没有一点苦
Lucia: Does this taste a bit bitter?
Lucia: 有没有一点点像啊
Alice:有可能
Shure:  what's this
Shure: What's this?
Katrina:  这就是压花器
Katrina: This is a flower press.
Katrina:  就是你把那个鲜花放进去
Katrina: You put the fresh flowers in it.
Katrina:  它就会变成干花
Katrina: It turns them into dried flowers.
Tasha: 这么粗买几个
Tasha: How many did you buy?
Tasha: 一个哎三三个
Tasha: One, uh, three.
Tasha: 别把他漏了
Tasha: Don't leave him out.
Tasha: 4个漏出来
Tasha: Four, left out.
Lucia: 这个地方他偏平一点
Lucia: This place is a bit flatter.
Lucia: 这是不是一个相对平坦的一个
Lucia: Isn't this relatively flat?
Lucia: 嗯显得太小
Lucia: Hmm, it looks too small.
Lucia: 有可能会是这样
Lucia: It could be like that.
Tasha: 啊不行啊这是太平了
Tasha: Ah no, this is too flat.
Tasha: 也许是了
Lucia: 一般相似先放在这里好了
Lucia: Usually put similar ones here first.
Tasha: 那把它按在这里面的哪里呢
Tasha: Then where do we press it in here?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 好问题
Lucia: 这个有可能吧
Lucia: Could be possible.
Lucia: 是不是也不太可能呀
Lucia: Or maybe not.
Lucia: 好迷惑啊我
Lucia: I'm so confused
Lucia: 我小时候玩那个1,000块拼图
Lucia: When I was a kid, I used to play with those 1,000-piece puzzles
Lucia: 从来没有拼出来过
Lucia: I never finished one
Tasha: 真的吗对我每次后面有数字
Tasha: Really? I always had numbers on the back
Tasha: 啊是吗
Tasha: Oh, really?
Katrina:  是呀哎
Katrina: Yeah, that's right
Lucia: 那难道我买的是盗版的
Lucia: Did I buy a fake one then?
Lucia: 反正我就是
Lucia: Anyway, I just
Lucia: 我好不容易拼了其中的一部分
Lucia: I barely managed to complete a part of it
Lucia: 然后就不会拼了
Lucia: And then I couldn't continue
Lucia: 然后我就放弃
Lucia: So I gave up
Lucia: 好难呀
Alice: 玩困了怎么办怎么说呢
Tasha: 这个应该
Alice: 催眠了
Tasha: 喝杯咖啡吧
Tasha: Have a cup of coffee
Shure:  嗯喝杯咖啡喝
Tasha: Yeah, have a cup of coffee
Lucia: 太难了
Lucia: It's too hard
Alice: 感觉他俩是不是也可以这样
Lucia: 速度
Alice: 就一点点就成这样了
Alice: Just a little bit, and it's like this
Shure:  这么多
Shure: So much
Katrina:  对但是我以为每
Katrina: Right, but I thought everyone
Katrina:  个人都要做
Katrina: Had to do
Katrina:  一到两边边都不播放了
Katrina: One or two, the edges don't play anymore
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Tasha: 大家挤一挤
Tasha: Everyone squeeze in
Lucia: 哈哈边不够了
Lucia: Haha, there's not enough space on the edge
Tasha: 嗯大家挤挤
Tasha: 勉强
Tasha: 哎就这样
Tasha: Okay, like this
Lucia: 就是这样的哈哈
Lucia: That's how it is, haha
Lucia: 非常对
Lucia: Exactly
Tasha: 我感觉边是对了
Tasha: I feel like the edges are correct
Alice:但我感觉这有点大
Alice: But I feel like it's a bit big
Tasha: 嗯但是感觉这边要重新组合组合
Tasha: Hmm, but it feels like this side needs to be reassembled
Tasha: 我觉得这边没问题
Tasha: I think this side is fine
Tasha: 这边这边有问题
Tasha: This side, this side has problems
Tasha: 要把这几个重新组合一下
Tasha: We need to reassemble these few pieces
Tasha: 但还是这几个边
Tasha: But still, these edges
Lucia: 总感觉这个牛
Lucia: I always feel like this cow
Lucia: 这里他应该能放一个什么东西进来
Lucia: Here, it should fit something in
Lucia: 但是
Tasha: 是的
Lucia: 难道他也是一个
Lucia: Could it also be a
Lucia: 障眼法吗
Lucia: Is it a trick?
Katrina:  这样就可以扩延充足
Katrina: This way it can be extended fully.
Lucia: 这个看起来其实也像在边上一样
Lucia: This actually looks like it's on the side too.
Lucia: 看就是如果如果这样的话是吧
Lucia: Look, if it's like this, right?
Katrina:  你这个花瓶呢
Katrina: Where's your vase?
Katrina:  快递在哪看到的哦
Katrina: Where did you see the delivery?
Alice: 花瓶不是快递
Alice: The vase wasn't delivered.
Alice: 就在桌子上
Alice: It's on the table.
Alice: 有两个瓶子
Alice: There are two vases.
Tasha: 哎这个哎我买了6啊
Tasha: Oh, I bought six of these.
Jake: 哪一个取得了历史性的进步啊
Jake: Which one made the historical progress?
Tasha: 哈哈哈我们刚发现这是这样的
Tasha: Hahaha, we just found out it's like this.
Lucia: 然后这样又可以拼上哦
Lucia: And then you can piece it together like this.
Shure:  历史性的进步
Shure: Historical progress.
Lucia: 不错不错
Lucia: Not bad, not bad.
Lucia: 胜利在望哈哈
Lucia: Victory is in sight, haha.
Alice:空有点大感觉
Katrina:  6个我当时想的是一人一个放下
Katrina: I thought we could each have one.
Katrina:  嗯6个花瓶
Katrina: Yeah, six vases.
Katrina:  好像都到了
Katrina: Seems like they all arrived.
Shure:  这个跟这个上的
Shure: This one goes with this one.
Alice: 但是这感觉
Alice: But this feels...
Lucia: 这个有可能在里面
Lucia: This might be inside.
Lucia: 感觉它看起来好像都不太圆对吧
Lucia: It looks like it's not very round, right?
Lucia: 嗯先把它放
Lucia: Yeah, let's put it down first.
Lucia: 熊猫哎这个也很像在边上
Lucia: Panda, this one also looks like it's on the side.
Lucia: 有道理
Katrina: Makes sense, actually sent three deliveries.
Katrina:  但是都到了
Katrina: But they all arrived.
Alice: 换个边
Katrina: You guys switch sides.
Alice: 更不像哎
Alice: Looks even less like it.
Tasha: 这个感觉屏有点那种弧度
Alice:是他吗？ 不是不是这个也不是
Alice: No, no, this isn't it either.
Alice:恩，放不下
Lucia: 如果把那个鸟嘴冲着那边就是
Lucia: If you point the bird's beak that way...
Lucia: 这样的话嗯好像也放不进去
Lucia: If we do it this way, it seems like it won't fit either.
Lucia: 这些东西有可能吗
Lucia: Are these things possible?
Katrina:  哇你已经弄好了
Katrina: Wow, you've already finished.
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Lucia: How did you get the scissors?
Katrina:  剪刀在外面
Katrina: The scissors are outside.
Katrina:  这加水了吗
Katrina: Did you add water to this?
Katrina:  加过了加过了
Katrina: Added, added.
Katrina:  是吧
Katrina: Right?
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow
Lucia: 哇哇
Lucia: Wow wow
Alice: 太难了太难了
Tasha: 哈哈，拼图天才
Lucia: 又找到一块
Tasha: 拼图天才
Tasha: 出世出山
Tasha: Emerged from nowhere
Jake: 真有意思
Jake: This is really interesting
Lucia: 让我们看看有没有可能
Lucia: Let's see if it's possible
Lucia: 在不依靠
Lucia: Without relying on
Lucia: 解析的情况下
Lucia: Any analysis
Jake: 这尾巴试过
Jake: Have you tried this tail?
Alice: 有点大
Alice: It's a bit big
Lucia: 这个呢有可能
Lucia: How about this one? Maybe
Lucia: 不太行
Lucia: Not quite
Lucia: 现在谁在中间呢
Lucia: Who's in the middle now?
Tasha: 嗯刚刚这个好像不太行
Tasha: Hmm, this one doesn't seem to fit
Alice: 他又跟谁分家了
Alice: Who did it split from?
Tasha: 对他他在这
Tasha: Yeah, it's here
Tasha: 哎把小伙伴丢了
Tasha: Oh no, lost its buddy
Lucia: 哦这个这个这个在他的
Lucia: Oh, this one, this one, this one is...
Lucia: sorry忘记了
Lucia: Sorry, I forgot
Lucia: 嗯对这是这样子的
Lucia: Yeah, it's like this
Lucia: 对对对这块就这样挺好
Lucia: Yes, yes, this piece fits well
Tasha: 这样子挺好的
Tasha: This piece fits well
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one
Tasha: 这个还不确定在哪
Tasha: Still not sure where it goes
Alice: 嗯
Alice: 确定在放中间吧
Alice: 你觉得这个像不像
Alice: Do you think this looks right?
Tasha: 像
Tasha: Yeah, it does
Alice: 好先找找你的位置
Tasha: Okay, let's find your place first
Katrina:  所有快递都在外面了吗对
Katrina: Are all the packages outside? Yes
Jake: 今天还到了几个
Jake: A few more arrived today
Jake: 但是还都会有管家过来送
Jake: But the butler will deliver them
Shure:  还有管家
Shure: There's a butler?
Tasha: 那他能把我的送来吗
Shure: Can he deliver mine?
Jake: 什么东西啊
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 把什么东西
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha: 把我买的东西
Tasha: Yang Ming, the stuff I bought
Tasha: 那应该是很好的
Tasha: It should be really good
Jake: 可以啊今天会有吗没有
Jake: Sure, will it be today? No?
Jake: 我问一下他们什么时候能
Jake: I'll ask them when they can.
Tasha: 好这游戏三个人玩刚刚好我们的
Tasha: Okay, this game is perfect for three people.
Alice: 掌管120度
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 不太像
Lucia: Not really.
Alice: 他俩是不是一家的
Alice: Are they from the same family?
Tasha: 他们仨是不是一个家的
Tasha: Are all three of them from the same family?
Lucia: 有可能但是总觉得哎
Lucia: Maybe, but it feels like, hmm...
Lucia: 这里是不是应该稍微弧度再推一点
Lucia: Shouldn't this angle be pushed a bit more?
Tasha: 可是感觉不是那么严丝合缝
Tasha: But it doesn't feel like a perfect fit.
Tasha: 他们俩的宽度最匹配
Tasha: The width of these two matches best.
Lucia: 然后放一下
Lucia: Then place it here.
Tasha: 抱着这个呢
Tasha: Holding onto this?
Tasha: 这两个都有可能
Tasha: Both of these are possible.
Katrina:  要帮忙不
Katrina: Need help?
Tasha: 哎你觉得这个像不像在这
Tasha: Hey, do you think this fits here?
Tasha: 这样子的这样
Tasha: Like this?
Alice: 像不像
Katrina: Does it fit? What is this?
Katrina:  我感觉这个可以
Katrina: I think this works.
Katrina:  不喜欢拧螺丝
Katrina: I don't like screwing bolts.
Alice: 不过这个头对着他的屁股
Alice: But this head matches his tail.
Alice: 好像也挺颜色合缝的
Alice: It seems to fit color-wise too.
Tasha: 这个这个是对的
Tasha: This one is correct.
Jake: 喜欢拧螺丝
Jake: Likes screwing bolts.
Jake: 就是刚刚拧的太紧了
Jake: Just screwed it too tight earlier.
Jake: 对对要不装个鸡
Jake: Yeah, yeah, how about we install a chicken?
Tasha: 咱俩配对啊
Tasha: Shall we pair up?
Shure:  要不咱装个鸡
Shure: How about we install a chicken?
Shure:  好给你买一个台电脑
Shure: Okay, I'll buy you a computer.
Jake: 从头装哇
Jake: Assemble from scratch, wow.
Alice:不太像
Jake: 怎么出来的
Jake: How did it come out?
Tasha: 这个是吗
Tasha: Is this the one?
Alice: 有长这样的吗
Tasha: Do any look like this?
Alice: 没有吧
Lucia: 这个也有点像
Lucia: 嗯因为好像长这样的弄出来的
Lucia: Yeah, because it seems like it's made like this.
Alice: 没有，这说明他们应该不是
Tasha: 这个暂且配对吧
Tasha: Let's pair this up for now.
Alice:这能加进去吗，不能加进去
Alice: 这我感觉这样应该
Alice: I feel like this should...
Alice: 很勉强但不是不行
Alice: It's a bit forced, but it's not impossible.
Jake: 试试笔画
Jake: Try the strokes.
Jake: 笔画这个跟谁都能配
Jake: The strokes can match with anyone.
Tasha: 这个我们两个的智商
Tasha: This is our combined IQ.
Shure:  不看那什么可以吗
Shure: Can we skip that part?
Tasha: 我就说我是个拼图天使
Tasha: I told you, I'm a puzzle angel.
Alice: 我这个在亮吗
Alice: Is mine lighting up?
Alice: 为什么感觉这是红色的
Jake: 在亮在亮在亮在亮
Jake: It's lighting up, it's lighting up, it's lighting up.
Shure:  没问题看一下安装图纸
Shure: No problem, let's check the installation guide.
Jake: 是红色你这电量太少了
Jake: It's red, your battery is too low.
Jake: 我看一下你的这个电在哪啊
Jake: Let me see where your battery is.
Shure:  这个是我我看一下这个对
Shure: This is mine, let me check this, right.
Shure:  放下面的
Shure: Put it at the bottom.
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Katrina:  跟他对接
Katrina: Connect it to him.
Shure:  这有两个螺丝
Shure: There are two screws here.
Alice: 这在录吗
Alice: Is this recording?
Jake: 这个在录
Jake: This is recording.
Jake: 然后这个正在拉
Jake: And this is pulling.
Jake: 所以没关系
Jake: So it's fine.
Jake: 然后吧对
Jake: Then, yes.
Jake: 这就是电开关
Jake: This is the power switch.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 这是干嘛的嗯
Jake: What's this for, hmm?
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina:  叠开关
Katrina: Stacking switches.
Katrina:  游戏
Katrina: Game.
Katrina:  高度调节
Katrina: Height adjustment.
Katrina:  你把它反过来是不是这
Katrina: Did you flip it over like this?
Jake: oh
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  holy shit what
Shure: Holy shit, what?
Shure:  what
Shure: What?
Shure:  耶哈哈哈哈
Shure: Yay, hahaha.
Jake: 嗯不行
Jake: Hmm, not working.
Katrina:  要这样弄紧靠紧
Katrina: You need to tighten it like this.
Shure:  这样把这边然后
Shure: Do it like this, and then...
Jake: 哪个距离不对吗
Jake: Is the distance wrong?
Katrina:  确实该弄长一点
Katrina: It should be a bit longer.
Jake: 应该这个中间这个中间
Jake: It should be this, in the middle, this middle part.
Jake: 这个有点别扭的感觉
Jake: This feels a bit awkward.
Jake: 这个大概是这个哎
Jake: Maybe it's supposed to be like this.
Jake: 他是有斜度吗
Jake: Is it slanted?
Alice:感觉不是这个形状
Jake: 但不是他是直的呀
Jake: But no, it's straight.
Alice: 但我觉得他两好像可以
Tasha: 他俩好像是一起的
Tasha: They seem to be together.
小微 : 可能原本不是挨着这个屁股
Jake: Maybe originally it wasn't next to this, right.
Alice:对
Tasha: 因为他们俩缝紧一些
Katrina: Make it tighter at this length.
Jake: 他这个他这个得弄长一点吗
Jake: Should we make it longer?
Katrina:  可以他是可以调节长度的对
Katrina: It can adjust the length, yes.
Lucia: 这样的话
Lucia: If that's the case...
Lucia: 哎不对不对不对不是这个得
Lucia: Wait, no, no, no, not this way.
Alice: 可能他不在这这样只是大概的
Jake: Maybe it's not here, this is just approximate.
Jake: 然后这个
Jake: And then this...
Lucia: 如果真的在一个台之后
Lucia: If it's really on one side after...
Lucia: 可能就变成这样了
Lucia: It might become like this.
Lucia: 但是我找不到了
Lucia: But I can't find it.
Tasha: 从中间这个如果没有的话就不是
Tasha: If it's not in the middle, then it's not right.
Tasha: 嗯好难呀
Tasha: Hmm, this is so hard.
Alice: 确实
Alice: Yeah, it is. Let's use a ruler next time.
Tasha: 也不知道谁和谁对
Shure: We don't even know which part matches with which.
Tasha: 是他们俩对还是他们俩不这样
Tasha: Whether these two match or not like this.
Shure:  嗯我们先把一一边固定上就好了
Shure: Hmm, let's fix one side first.
Shure:  让他不乱窜
Shure: So it doesn't move around.
Jake: 固定一个吧
Jake: Let's fix one side.
Jake: 嗯或者应该倒倒下来得了倒下来
Jake: Or maybe we should flip it over, just flip it over.
Lucia: 有点难搞
Lucia: This is a bit tricky.
Lucia: 感觉拼困了累了歇一歇
Lucia: I feel tired from assembling, let's take a break.
Tasha: 哎怎么突然拼那个需要帮忙呢
Tasha: Why did we suddenly need help with this?
Alice:真的有点困
Shure:  那个拿拿耳朵呢
Shure: Can you get the ear?
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Jake: 你们听完了没有
Jake: Did you guys finish listening?
Jake: 先休息一会是吧
Jake: Let's take a break, right?
Jake: 对听困了
Jake: Yeah, listening made us tired.
Lucia: 决定看看有没有什么其他可以帮忙的
Shure: Let's see if there's anything else we can help with.
Jake: 我们房间要不要
Jake: Do we need...
Jake: 我可能要装饰一下
Jake: Maybe we should decorate our room.
Jake: 要不我们踩个风
Jake: Or should we take a break?
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia: 我们是只只把一楼这个客厅装饰一下
Lucia: Let's just decorate the living room on the first floor.